oh why someone once said what has been
will be again what has been done will be
done again there is nothing new under
the sun and by someone i mean the book
of ecclesiastes from the tonka or the
christian old testament
and this bit of knowledge has maintained
its relevance more than 2 000 years
later especially when it comes to the
fiction we enjoy and i'm not just saying
that because i'm rereading the latest
new york times bestseller retelling of
pride and prejudice not saying i'm not
but from james joyce's ulysses to
bridget jones's diary you've probably
read a book that was just a modern
retelling of a well-established story
which is to say nothing of other forms
of media and their own obsessions with
retelling and rebooting and despite what
your writing 101 instincts might tell
you this is neither bad nor lazy writing
or even a new concept because let's be
honest sometimes a story is just so dang
good it bears repeating sometimes more
than once sometimes multiple times i'm
looking at you miss jane austen
[Music]
so why do we retell stories to put it
simply in wild's words there is art
found not in a works perceived
originality but in the way the artist
has used or deliberately not used and
arranged pre-existing thoughts and
motifs to make something that is
entirely their own
so with that let's take a look at three
authors who engage in literary upcycling
and compare starting with the bard
himself great gay of history william
shakespeare that's right our billy boy
would probably be rocking an archive of
our own account today written centuries
before wattpad was a twinkle in the
internet's collective eye many of
shakespeare's works are retellings of
historical events or common narratives
that were already well established in
elizabethan england
according to professor gordon mcmullen
director of the london shakespeare
center at king's college
with almost no exception shakespeare got
his stories from elsewhere and reworked
them in his own way the point was
everyone did this the concept of
originality like genius was invented at
the end of the 18th century and for
immigrant children everywhere i wish it
had stayed there personally even works
as ubiquitous and widely taught as romeo
and juliet and hamlet are retellings of
some other story the former being based
on a 1562 english translation of an
italian poem the tragical history of
romeous and juliet by arthur brooke the
latter being derived primarily from the
medieval scandinavian legend of amleth
and perhaps more alluringly from what is
referred to er hamlet a play of unknown
origin published more than a decade
earlier in 1587 which some scholars
believe may have been written by thomas
keed shakespeare's contemporary then
there are his historical plays which
take a very loose but poetic take on
real life figures like julius caesar and
king richard iii bts fan fiction has
nothing on shakespeare's take on henry v
for example reshaping the lancaster
monarch of england as not just a war
hero but as a complex and sometimes
unscrupulous ruler whose military
ambition comes at the cost of tremendous
violence and bloodshed whole academic
careers have been devoted to the study
of shakespeare's henri ad plays
dissecting how the texts paralleled and
prophesized events in the playwright's
contemporary england and the rise of the
tudor dynasty and yet as much as we
think of them as high literature today
shakespeare's works at the time were
seen as popcorn for the unwashed masses
that is easily available written in
language that was easily understandable
to poor uneducated folk and
cheap rehashes professors jessica mccall
and kavita mudan finn perhaps capture
best the uncanny parallels between how
shakespeare's retellings and modern fan
fiction works saying amongst fans and
the academics who study them it is
generally accepted perhaps even at truth
universally acknowledged that a good
portion of what we consider canonical
literature including shakespeare also
fits the broadest definition of fan
fiction in that it is clearly written in
response to or adapting a specific
source text although it is difficult to
reconcile any category that comfortably
includes both shakespeare's plays and el
james for the shades of grey
89
of which had already appeared on the
internet as a piece of twilight fan
fiction entitled master of the universe
some have argued that this juxtaposition
is the very point of fandom
but shakespeare was hardly the first or
last person to throw his hat into the
retelling ring and come out the victor
nor was he the only person making
modernized hay out of antiquity and we
can't talk about modernized retellings
without talking about james joyce and
the sprawling work that is his ulysses
dear god
ulysses is based on that flagship of
high school literature the odyssey
homer's ancient greek epic poem
concerning its titular hero odysseus
and the many perils he faces trying to
return home to his kingdom in ithaca and
fyi ulysses is just a roman version of
the name odysseus for the for the nerds
out there that wanted to make sure i
pointed that out aka me a fixture of
study joyce was hardly the first person
to grapple with retelling the odyssey
however what joyce ended up creating is
considered one of the most important
modernist texts of the 20th century in
place of odysseus is leopold bloom and
instead of spanning a decade in ancient
greece his adventures occur over one
june day in modern dublin where the
odyssey is comprised of 24 chapters
ulysses roughly corresponds to them in
18 stream of conscious segments
brimming with characters and plot
situations that all directly are lifted
from the source material your penelope's
your stephen daedaluses and whatnot but
joyce uses these similarities to convert
odysseus trials into the psychological
feeling of being lost
lost to modern conceptions of day-to-day
living lost to feelings of national
identity lost in ireland's relationship
to the united kingdom from his 1980
introduction to the work canadian
literary scholar william hugh kenner
remarked ulysses and the odyssey are
identical in not existing save as
manifestations of human creative power
products of an artistic process that is
like a natural process
and that intuits in many times
comparable situations whether in the
mind of homer of kiosk or in the mind of
james augustine joyce
both far from the scenes of their
stories created their heroes and
recreate an epic geography both were
gutted by the circumstances they knew
warfare seafaring marvels
commerce per ambulation
novelties all this to say that james
joyce was what the kids might refer to
as the true godfather of the modern a.u
that is the writer who is able to take a
story older than written tradition and
definitely draw significance from both
the similarities and differences by
placing it in a new setting
so this is why i toil and labor over my
inuyasha fan fiction because you know
what lorcheshomer needs to be in present
day so that he can be with me
speaking of female desire misunderstood
by audiences no video essay about modern
retellings would be complete without
talking about the queen herself jane
austen and the profound legacy she has
left to literature and its fascination
with retellings i bring up austin not
because her novels are specifically
retellings though she herself often used
well-worn romantic and comedic
contrivances that had long existed in
literature and contemporized them for
her own readers but because of the
profound impact her body of work had on
the modern commercial novel and media in
general from bridget jones's diary to
clueless to send sensibility in sea
monsters if we have one socially
acceptable cachet for stories of
retelling outside of shakespeare it's
our girl jane i don't think there's a
way to capture this vibe succinctly so
here's just some of the novels that are
direct retellings of her work this
doesn't even begin to touch on film
comic book and television reiterations
of her work in which we have an
eight-hour long episode and this is a
publicly funded program so we're not
trying to waste your money with that
although go watch pbs's adaptation of
sandington arguably the most financially
successful from this list is helen
fielding's bridget jones diary and its
sequel the edge of reason based on
austin's novels pride and prejudice and
persuasion though the bridget jones
character existed before the publication
of both books as a recurring fictional
columnist for the independent when
writing her book fielding saw the
parallels between jones obsession with
modern femininity fashion and dating and
the way austin's elizabeth bennett finds
herself constantly struggling with the
social mores of regency england said
fielding rather cheekily when asked if
she lifted the plot of her books from
austin quote i thought both plot and
leading man had been well-marked
researched over a number of centuries
and that jane austen wouldn't mind
anyways she's dead austin wrote about
the minutia of women's lives in a way
that is funny and dazzlingly accurate
giving you insight into what was going
on in the social world without you're
even realizing you're getting an
incredible history lesson but we reach a
conundrum here despite bridget jones's
diary's success there is an issue
for all of the austin retellings that
exist in the market almost all of them
are relegated to the dreaded genre of
chicklet or women's literature
because we don't just read
why is it that if we can peg down
shakespeare and james joyce as
artistically acceptable examples of
literary recyclists that we look at
books like britta jones's diary or jenny
lee's best-selling retelling of anna
karenina anna k as disposable or
barely a step above fan fiction which
again shouldn't be an insult anyway
we've already done an episode in part on
this click on the link above but to be
succinct retellings especially ones sold
as retellings are a big part of genres
that tend to skew towards marginalized
audiences audiences with women with
lgbtq plus people and bypoc audiences
and that's a whole basket of
conceptually difficult apples to unpack
we'd be picking through those and those
dynamics for another 12 hours and again
this is a
publicly funded video
but i think these actually speak to a
larger truth about why retellings exist
and why we keep coming back to them
says scholar slash professor richard
nygar
stories shape our sense of self who we
believe we are our sense of our own
inherited privileges and misfortunes our
affinities identifications and
allegiances
stories also shape what we wish or hope
to do in order to give our existence
meaning whom we want to stand or fight
with whom or what we want to help or
rescue in order to uphold what we think
is ethical
or just telling stories involves making
decisions or moves and each retelling of
a familiar story may either give birth
to new meanings nuances and affects
or erase their possibility thus each
storyteller can be seen as a translator
of stories with the responsibility to
retell stories in ways that can do
justice to them
that is that the saying there is nothing
new under the sun
is not an inherently negative statement
rather that stories persevere because
they have some universality to them that
has their time and place as society
moves away
and towards them again
then minutia may change the trappings
different
but when we tell a story we are asked to
consider its power what does the story
say about where we came from what does
it mean about where we are now and where
we are going and while necessity might
be the mother of invention
it is in repetition we find these truths
all this to say please pre-order my
reimagining of frog and toad titled
durable and hamster
[Music]
before you go we wanted to invite you to
participate in pbs digital studios
annual audience survey your feedback
really helps us understand what our
audience is interested in so we can give
you more of it you even get to vote on
potential new shows there's a link in
the description below if you have a few
minutes we love your input
thanks
you